-Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
You guys,
it is Veterans Day,
and, tonight,
our entire audience is made up
of veterans, active military,
and military families.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Please, have a seat.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome.
That's right. It's just like our
Fleet Week audience but sober.
[ Laughter ]
All kidding aside, I want to say
thank you for your service.
You truly are the bravest.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean it.
The closest most of us have come
to a war zone is shopping
on Black Friday at TJ Maxx.
[ Laughter ]
"Give that to me!
It's not even my size."
Yep, the only people who have
seen more combat than you guys
are flight attendants
on Southwest.
[ Laughter ]
I remember -- I remember telling
my dad that I thought
a life in uniform
might be right for me,
so he went out and got me
a job application for Pizza Hut.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
Sadly, they said no.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the Space Force
couldn't be here tonight.
They're busy --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're busy monitoring
the galaxy for missiles,
aliens, and our newest threat,
bored billionaires.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of restaurants
offered special deals today.
Servicemembers could get a free
bloomin' onion at Outback.
[ Cheers ]
Free pancakes at IHOP.
And a free doughnut
at Krispy Kreme.
[ Cheers ]
And if you ate all three,
we have an ambulance outside
standing by, so don't worry.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let's get to the news.
The Postmaster General just said
that the U.S. Postal Service
is ready for
the holiday-package rush.
Unfortunately, the holiday
they're talking about
is July 4th.
[ Laughter ]
But still, they're ready.
That's right.
The post office is prepared,
meaning they "prepared" hundreds
of signs that say
"Next window please."
[ Laughter ]
That's right. They said that
they're ready for the rush.
Although I don't know how I feel
about the new slogan,
"United States Postal Service:
We can handle your package."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-You can't say that.
-Why would you say that?
-You can't say that anymore.
You can't --
♪♪
-Package.
-Some business news.
The tuna lawsuit
against Subway,
the sandwiches, is back.
Yeah, and now, they're saying
that the tuna contains chicken,
pork, and cattle DNA.
[ Audience groans ]
Even crazier, when they tested
Subway's chicken and pork,
they found it was 100% tuna.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, chicken, pork,
and cattle DNA.
Right now, Subway's thinking,
"All things considered,
not bad."
[ Laughter ]
"They're all meats, right?"
Yep, Subway's like,
"What do you want from us?
It's fish served
with an ice-cream scoop.
Come on.
What do you want?"
[ Laughter ]
It's not like Morimoto's
sharpening his knives
back there, cutting it up.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I read that the CEO
of Royal Caribbean said that
the company is seeing
historically strong bookings
for cruises next summer.
Right now, members of
the Coast Guard and Navy
are looking at each other, like,
"So, you guys gonna handle this,
or should we?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Carnival Cruises
still hasn't let people
off the boats from March 2020.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"No, not yet.
Not looking good.
More tuna!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Royal Caribbean
said it's expecting
record profits,
and then the CEO of Imodium
was like, "Same here."
[ Laughter ]
Some --
[ Chuckles ]
Some air -- thank you.
Some airline --
Some airline news.
The FAA has proposed
more than $200,000 in fines
for 10 unruly passengers.
Yeah.
And this is nice.
Starting today,
if you're flying from Florida,
they ask if you want
to pre-pay your fine.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
-"Hold my -- Hold my Four Loko.
That's unbelievable!"
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- I read that
a new survey found that 80%
of Americans use slang words
but only half
know what the slang terms
they use actually mean.
[ Laughter ]
Those aren't great numbers,
so I thought
I'd help everyone brush up
on their slang definitions
with a tiny song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra
means "over the top" ♪
♪ Spill the tea means
you should share the goss ♪
♪ Receipts are proof ♪
♪ If you seem sus,
sus is short for suspicious ♪
♪ Gucci's cool
and flex is showing off ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Curves is when you ignore
a flirty text ♪
♪ No cap means "for real,"
"We move" means "yes" ♪
♪ Simping's
when you like someone ♪
♪ But do too much for them ♪
♪ And simps are almost stans
but just not -- ♪
Dang! Sorry.
Let me do it one more time.
Can I do it one more time?
Hoo! All right, I'm close.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, don't waste your time
clapping because who knows
how many takes
I got to do this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Be exhausted.
-Go wash your hands.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You'll be asleep by the time --
Oh, here we go.
-My hands are numb.
-All right, here we go.
[ Tapping ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
♪ Acting ♪
[ Taps ]
Oh.
-I thought
I was having a stroke.
I didn't know
what was happening.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-I had IHOP pancakes.
I had a Krispy Kreme.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra -- ♪
Nope.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, bud.
♪ Acting extra -- ♪
Yeah, there you go.
All right, here we go.
Ready?
[ Laughter ]
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra
means over the top ♪
♪ Spill the tea means
you should share the goss ♪
♪ Receipts are proof ♪
♪ If you seem sus,
sus is short for suspicious ♪
♪ Gucci's cool,
and flex is showing off ♪
You don't have
to be silent, either.
I mean, you can --
[ Laughter ]
Like a funeral, for God's sake.
Did someone die?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
-I was hearing --
I was hearing tapping from --
I was hearing tapping
from the 10th floor!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Gosh.
You said, "Don't clap."
-I did say, "Don't clap."
Yeah, I -- Why am I gonna say,
"Don't clap"?
-You said no clapping.
-Clap. Do whatever you want.
You didn't say laugh.
-I could hear someone
chewing gum, it was so quiet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And it was off beat, too!
That was the worst part.
[ Laughter ]
-All right,
I'm gonna get this now.
[ Laughter ]
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra
means over the top ♪
♪ Spill the tea means
you should share the goss ♪
♪ Receipts are proof ♪
♪ If you seem sus,
sus is short for suspicious ♪
♪ Gucci's cool,
and flex is showing off ♪
[ Cheers ]
♪ Curve's when you ignore
a flirty text ♪
♪ No cap means for real,
"We move" means "yes" ♪
♪ Simping's when
you like someone ♪
♪ But do too much for them ♪
♪ And simps are almost stans
but not quite yet ♪
[ Cheers ]
♪ "Slept on" means
something deserves more heat ♪
♪ And if you want to say
woo-hoo say yeet ♪
-Yeet!
-♪ So now you know
the slang to drop ♪
♪ The next time that you speak ♪
♪ These all will be outdated
by next week ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-No, no, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
[ Both laugh ]
Thank you very much
for being so patient.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, a man in France
set a world record
for standing
on top of a hot-air balloon
nearly 12,000 feet in the sky.
Check this out.
[ Light laughter ]
-What?
-The only thing more dangerous
is eating the tuna at Subway.
[ Laughter ]
When he came back down, he was
like, "Yeah, still no signal."